the latest in a series of attempted
replacements for fired Fox News
propagandist Tucker Carlson is Donald
Trump's own former press secretary one
of the most dishonest people in the
Trump Administration Kaylee mcinanny she
gets this week to try replacing
propagandist Tucker Carlson her first
episode last night was a pathetic joke
the likes of which you would find at the
bottom of a barrel a media Barrel a
proverbial media Barrel she opened her
own show
by showing some of her speech at the
2020 Republican National Committee I'm
not going to play it but we're just
showing you you know a screenshot from
that her first guest was the Texas
Attorney General and he was on not to
talk about we've got to do something
about guns we've had this terrible
shooting in Texas and Allen no no no no
no the Texas Attorney General appeared
with Kaylee mcinanny Ken Paxton to talk
about how bad gender affirming care is
for Trans kids and then this was really
just the cherry on top I guess we would
call it former democratic congresswoman
Tulsi gabbard appeared to call Trans
people mentally ill and essentially say
that there's no such thing as trans she
says really crazy things here and this
is one of the most disgusting one of the
most disgusting Tucker Carlson villains
that I've seen so far let's listen to
the last real liberal remember when all
these supposed leftists were saying the
only real left-winger running in 2020 is
Tulsi listen to this
well Kaylee this should give us some
hope to see that there is still some
sense of of Common Sense and Sanity in
our society because this is the real
question that we the American people are
being faced with we have leaders in the
Democratic party unfortunately and those
in our society who are are pushing this
fantasy they are asking us to take
something that is clearly not real and
believe that it's real they're asking us
to take something that is very clearly
amended it's not real so illness that
creates this delusion where you have
people saying well I'm a man in a
woman's body and what's weird about the
mental illness thing is that for a long
time
homosexuality was very clearly a mental
illness in the DSM Etc and then we sort
of like came to our senses and realized
just about every animal species has a
percentage of what we would call
um
I don't know if the term homosexual is
used for other species but you
understand what I'm saying and then we
realize oh actually like there there's
this isn't a mental illness we should
stop trying to like treat it with
medication or convert people out of it
because that's crazy and and so that was
revised and so now she's just going with
well this is clearly just a mental
illness vice versa and then doctors
committing in the case of children
especially this medical malpractice
trying to turn this fantasy into reality
and creating incredibly negative short
and long-term consequences both this is
nuts okay tool C is nuts physically and
psychologically and so that's really the
question that we the American people
have to to ask ourselves and to answer
is are we going to live in a society of
Common Sense and reality or are we going
to buy into this Insanity uh and this
fantasy are we going to allow and this
is one of the reasons I left the
Democratic parties right now we know why
she left we have the Democratic party of
today uh selling this fantasy and and
Catering to it and giving credibility to
this fantasy these mental Illusions all
because they think it'll give them more
political power a party that is willing
to do anything especially things that
are damaging to Children right this is
so crazy the idea that you're going to
get so this so I don't even know so as
far as the Kaylee filling in for Tucker
it's a joke it's just terrible but she
was better than some of the people who
have tried so far but the the content
was just absolutely disgusting the idea
that it I don't know at this point what
the prevalence of
um of trans is in the general population
and part of it is are are we actually
correctly assessing that number is
everybody even kind of willing to say it
or but it it seems like it's
extraordinarily small it's under well
under one percent
the idea that the Democratic Party
has this Brave and Bold exciting
strategy to gain political power
by catering to the I'm using their
terminology by quote catering to the
quote delusions
of
a tiny tiny tiny tiny sliver of the
population
it's just a very stupid strategy and
obviously that's not what it is it's
about a reaction to the rights attack on
this marginalized group of people that's
what we're dealing with here so tulsi's
lost her mind
um the Tucker replacement Fiasco is not
going well and we'll continue following
it to see what happens with Fox news
they've got another at least one more
lawsuit at least two more lawsuits
they're dealing with maybe three we will
follow it all of the clips I played here
for you
can find them on our YouTube channel you
can find them on our Instagram on our
Tick Tock they're really almost too
available to be perfectly honest if
you're looking for the perfect Mother's
Day gift our sponsor Aura frames creates
incredible Ultra quality digital frames
we're displaying pictures and videos you
can pre-load the frame with your
favorite memories pictures videos for
Mom to see when she opens it up you can
update it with unlimited photos and
videos from anywhere using the aura
frames app no fees ever no limits on
storage Aura frames was voted the number
one digital picture frame by wire cutter
the strategist and Wired Magazine my mom
loves the frame I gave her I also have
an aura frame in my house when we were
just traveling I was able to immediately
add pictures which pop up on my mom's
frame and I've noticed the photos look
like real prints such high resolution
and the display is calibrate so that you
can not even tell it's a screen Aura
frames has an awesome Mother's Day deal
for my audience you'll get up to thirty
dollars off their best-selling Carver
map frame and free shipping go to
auraframes.com Pacman use the code
Pacman the link is in the description